what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson and last night I watched
werewolf by night and
something I want to stress right off the
bat I really want this to to sink into
people's heads if you follow the channel
for a while
if you've watched a live stream if you
followed me on Instagram or Twitter you
probably know that I don't like scary
creepy horror ghost any type of that
stuff any like creepy type of stuff I
don't like I really don't so when Marvel
announced werewolf by night I'm like
that's pretty cool because
You Know Jack Russell from the comics
blah blah blah blah like the nerd I am
thought that was cool but internally I
was like I'm going to have to watch this
I'm going to have to do a review on this
um and I I was concerned because I don't
typically like that kind of stuff and
I'm just kind of like I hope I'm not
like extremely biased but I watched it
and I gotta say
I loved it
like I really
loved it which was is like a big
surprise to me like a huge surprise to
me I I don't like this type of stuff
like I really don't like even The Adams
Family
I don't like because it gives off
that kind of creepy vibe to me which
makes me just kind of like makes my skin
crawl I don't know why like I can watch
those movies I just don't enjoy them at
all I just I really don't and I get why
some people do like them because it's an
adrenaline rush and all that stuff but
to me it's the opposite effect however
werewolf by night I was on the edge of
my seat the entire time and I loved it I
was sitting there like I was leaning
forward because I watched it on my
computer I was leaning forward like more
and more like I found myself like
leaning on my desk
when I watched this
and I was so taken back
that I liked it so much I think most
people know Greg Alba from the real
rejects I texted him right before I
watched it and he was like dude it's
awesome and I was like ah and he was
like yeah but you don't like that stuff
so I don't know I'm like yeah I really
don't know and I text him after I'm like
dude that was freaking awesome
it was really cool it was really cool
especially I don't know like it was
creepy I I think the people who do like
that stuff
are still going to to really feel like
they dove in for that and I interviewed
the one of The Producers last night and
that's what they set out to do he said
they set out to make you know that
creepy movie that was inspired by like
you know these old Monster films in the
30s and I'm just so shocked that I liked
it so much and I said this on Instagram
I said this on Twitter uh it's actually
one of my favorite things to come from
Marvel Studios like period I that's how
much I loved it and um I think fans are
I've already seen some of this said
online some people were like oh I think
this is going to start Marvel's comeback
because a lot of people haven't been too
satisfied with phase four
um some people really like it some
people don't that's just how it is but I
think for those people who haven't liked
phase four so far I do think this is
going to be like sort of that comeback
for Marvel Studios that those people
might have been waiting for uh because I
loved it
oh
now I will say something
kind of about the MCU as a whole
I thought
Moon Knight was kicking off the
Supernatural and it and it did and I
loved Moon Knight I do
but this is I feel like this really is
kicking off like the supernatural like
like then blades next and stuff like
that like I feel like it's a very
different vibe right this is a very
different vibe than Moon Knight because
this is you know like the creepy and and
the monsters and stuff like that and
yeah we had some of those monsters in
Moon night but
this is like
this is cool and I don't know why I
think it's cool I really don't because I
don't typically like this stuff but the
story is good
um and I think that was like the main
thing that drove me to it and then just
the way they filmed it all this isn't a
review
um this is just my and reaction and
initial thoughts which as you can tell
are one I'm shocked and two I I really
really enjoyed it
it's kind of not gory not that's not the
right word but like it's it's it does
what it's supposed to do I would say
that they didn't hold back on this
um I I that's what I would say I would
say they set out to make
the film
that they wanted to make and that's what
they did and it is a film for those
asking uh it is I think it's like an
hour long
um it's a feature so I think like I
think we were talking about it in the
Press junket it was me Eric Voss Brandon
Davis uh John from the real Rejects and
jabby
um we were discussing what a feature is
and I guess it's anything over 45
minutes so it is a film
um and honestly it's one of my favorite
things to come from Marvel Studios as
weird as that sounds because those who
know me people who are really close to
me I don't
I don't do scary stuff for a quiet place
with John Krasinski that's not even like
a scary movie I don't know what that
would be to find as maybe a thriller I
didn't want to go and I was like I'm not
going to see that movie and a bunch of
my friends were going to see the movie
everybody knows that I love the movie
theater experience I love popcorn and
soda and all the stuff like that so my
friends literally went we will buy you
two tubs of popcorn if you just come to
the movie with us and there's like 10 of
10 people so it's like a whole group
thing and you know they obviously didn't
want me to you know not go with them and
I was like fine buy me the popcorn and
I'll go that that's how I feel about
creepy things and that's not even
supposed to be like a scary movie it's
like a like a thriller right but that's
how I feel so going into this I was like
oh man I don't
I don't necessarily want to watch this
but I do but uh I'm hesitant and I'm
just I'm crazy shocked that it's one of
my favorite things now um it really is
it's really cool I was like texting a
bunch of people I was like you guys are
gonna love this like it's awesome uh so
that's my initial reaction is that I am
so shocked at how much I liked it and I
think I think the Marvel fans are really
really going to enjoy this a lot
um there's some really cool MCU stuff in
it you know some connections and stuff
like that that's all I'll say uh but but
it's so cool it's so cool everything
from the way they filmed it to the story
to the characters I liked all the
characters actually yeah they were
really cool too so yeah get ready for
werewolf by night it comes out October
6th I believe
so around 10 days from now not too long
to wait it's a it's a perfect spooky
film for spooky season so fans are gonna
be excited
um I really really enjoyed it and
I hope everybody else does too because
it's it's awesome and it may be that
comeback that people are waiting for but
yeah once you see it I can't wait to
have a discussion about it we'll we'll
do one so I will catch you all next time
woof woof
thank you